president Trump scoops up 15 million
dollars in California we examine how the
bluest of blue states can help the
president win in 2020 then meanwhile
Democrats take their cues on global
affairs from a Swedish teenager as 16
year old environmental activist Greta
Thun Berg testifies before Congress we
get some good news on abortion bad news
on criminal justice and an embarrassing
report on the gratuity habits of
Millennials all that and more i'm
michael knowles and this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so sorry to say that I missed the
Trump fundraiser in Beverly Hills I
could have seen every single
conservative probably in the state of
California you can fit them just about
into one room he was there doing all
swing through California the past couple
days and he raised a lot of money which
is having some people on the left
scratch their heads has he about to
bring in all that money in a state that
overwhelmingly voted for Hillary Clinton
we'll get into the numbers because
California has always played a important
role in the conservative movement and I
think California could play a major role
in president Trump's re-election hopes
in 2020 but first I've got to talk about
ray con I love ray con ray con earbuds
start at about half the price of any
other premium wireless earbuds on the
market not going to name names but you
know the ones that I'm talking about and
Ray con earbuds sound just as good ray
cons a 50 wireless earbuds have
completely changed the game
the reason is other premium wireless
earbuds they're not that comfortable
they got weird stuff sticking out and
they don't always fit in your ear that
well and they just want to have a
one-size-fits-all overpriced solution
for everybody then you get those really
SuperDuper cheapo earbuds and they don't
work and they don't hold a charge and
you can barely hear what you're trying
to listen to rake on hits the sweet spot
they're super comfortable they're easy
to take anywhere they they are stylish
they are discreet they're not like
jumping out at you they're no dangling
wires or stems of course they don't just
look great they sound great - ray con
offers their wireless earbuds for
everyone in a range of fun colors not
just one and they got an unbeatable
price they're really terrific go to buy
rakin dot-com slash Knowles Canada wles
wireless earbuds are a must-have in the
21st century they completely changed the
game go out there get the best at a
great price and get 15% off your order
today by raking comm slash Knowles keno
wles
for 15% off rake on wireless earbuds if
you've been eyeing a pair now is the
time to get a great deal by rakin comm
slash Knowles speaking of great deals
President Trump got a great deal on his
two or three-day swing through
California he was just in Beverly Hills
and I think the total he's taking out of
that state is 15 million
bucks the big takeaway here for the left
for the chattering class is that 15
million bucks didn't come from nowhere
we talk about California as though it's
just monolithic completely leftist there
isn't a conservative anywhere I mean I
make jokes about it too but there are I
mean we used to have a group out in Los
Angeles called friends of Abe and
friends of Abe was friends of Abraham
Lincoln it was all the secret
conservatives in Hollywood there were a
lot of us they the the Obama
administration tried to get our lists of
our members they everyone wanted to know
who they were because if you asked
anybody in the industry they'd say I
don't know any conservatives out here I
don't meet any conservatives in
Hollywood and yet there were a lot they
just were afraid of speaking up because
the left is so vindictive in California
and it's it's I suppose this is what we
mean by the phrase the silent majority
Republicans conservatives have been
relying on that silent majority since
Nixon since Reagan and all the way up
through Trump there are different names
for them forgotten Americans the great
men and women of the middle of the
country whatever they're out there
they're even all the way in California I
think what Trump is seeing here is he
doesn't need to win California for
California to help him win in 2020 you
know it's true that Hillary Clinton won
California in a landslide Trump got four
and a half million votes there four and
a half million people voted for
President Trump in 2016 was the hole
that was the harder election to vote for
Trump because we didn't know what he was
gonna do we didn't know how he was going
to behave he's exceeded pretty much
everybody's expectations the we were
told the economy was going to collapse
we were told we're gonna go to World War
three we were told all the terrible
things would happen if Trump got elected
instead pretty much everything's
improved the economy is great we have
record low unemployment relative peace
abroad renegotiated trade deals things
are looking pretty good how many votes
is he gonna get in 2020 enough to win
almost certainly not but it could
galvanize some support for him four and
a half million votes in 2016 he also
raised three hundred thirty three
million dollars in California in 2016
that's a lot of money what this tells
you is there are Trump supporters in
California I know probably most of them
personally but there are there actually
are and it this isn't even a
left-right thing Trump made a central
pillar of his fundraising swing through
California how the cities are
deteriorating Los Angeles and San
Francisco
I live in LA LA is falling apart
homelessness is up 16% in just one year
in LA San Francisco is falling apart
there's drugs all over the street
they're decriminalizing homeless
behaviors there as well there's public
defecation on the street in San
Francisco you don't need to be some
rock-ribbed Reaganite Republican to say
this isn't good maybe we don't want this
maybe we want the state to move in
another direction so I think Trump is
very smart to bring this up to talk
about this I mean you're strong about LA
homelessness obviously the President of
the United States is probably not gonna
fix a municipal problem like la
homelessness but it's a symbol for the
rot at if it comes as a result of these
leftist policies more importantly even
than that I think and the reason why
Trump probably should swing back through
Hollywood next time he gets a chance is
just for the rest of the country he gets
to use Hollywood as a foil for him and
for his policies that liberal vindictive
Hollywood can be the foil it's like the
anti Trump I mean we saw just a few
weeks ago the stars of Will & Grace Eric
McCormack and Debra Messing who Trump
then nicknamed Debra the mess Messing in
his very trumpian way they came out and
they called for the public naming of any
Trump supporter in Hollywood we're
talking about McCarthyite blacklist
I even hesitate to use the term
McCarthyite to describe what they were
doing because at least Joe McCarthy was
going after communists at least Joe
McCarthy was going after enemies of
America those two Will and Grace were
going after people who support the
president and saying they said
explicitly we want you to name their
names so we know who not to work with we
want you to name their name so we know
who to blacklist who ruin their
reputations ruin their careers take away
their livelihood that is a bad look I
mean there was even some pushback from
liberal Hollywood about that and Trump
gets to come out there and one trigger
them I mean whip them up into that
frenzy and then show the rest of the
country so you have genuinely a choice
not an echo you know Hollywood
this widespread reach they are exporters
of culture and so well and grace going
out and calling for a blacklist maybe it
won't change votes in California it's
almost certainly not gonna flip
California to become some Republican
state but that sort of vindictive
leftism is not gonna play in Peoria that
vindictive leftism is not going to play
in the middle of the country where we're
looking at them and saying gosh if I
have to choose every election is a
better choice if I have to choose
between Trump who's given us a pretty
good economy you know he's got some mean
tweets but whatever they're pretty funny
and relative peace and he actually seems
pretty normal and I get to choose
between that or these lunatics out there
in Hollywood Who am I gonna pick
obviously you're gonna pick president
Trump how does he do it he does it
because he's a Hollywood figure the last
guy to use California in this way was
another Hollywood guy which was Ronald
Reagan you know the the conservative
movement in many ways the post-war
conservative movement came out of
California you had Bill Buckley in New
York and then you had Reagan in
California you head of Orange County
which used to be a Republican stronghold
now after decades and decades of
specifically illegal immigration
demographic changes have have made
California bluer but there are still a
lot of conservatives here it's a
gigantic state I mean if you can lose a
state in a landslide and still get four
and a half million votes it's worth
swinging by Trump knows that and I think
he's going to play Hollywood for all
it's worth he's already done this with
the media he's already done this in a
lot of other left-wing places and it's a
pretty wise so congratulations to him on
the 15 million bucks glad to hear that
conservatives in California are fired up
about it that's what's going on here
I mean that's how the Republicans are
are focusing their campaigns what is the
left doing that what are the Democrats
doing we'll get in a little bit to what
some of the presidential candidates are
talking about but over on Capitol Hill
while the Republican Party is talking
about homelessness talking about the
drug crisis talking about the economy
the left and Democrats are talking about
the Sun Monster they're talking about
global warming they're saying global
warming is going to kill us within 10
years or 12 years or 14 months or
whatever their big
expert that they've brought in to
testify on this question of global
warming is not a scientist though they
always tell us about how we need to
listen to the scientists it's not a
political philosophy or a policymaker
it's a 16-year old Swedish girl named
Greta Sundberg 16 year old Swedish girl
who at age 15 it became best known for
skipping school to protest global
warming outside of the Swedish
parliament what a racket good job kid
can you imagine 15 years old you decide
you want to skip school and then you
somehow convince your parents and your
teachers and the whole country and much
of the leftist world to applaud you for
it really really smart she's obviously a
firecracker she does that a 15 then she
starts organizing the school climate
strike movement so she encourages other
students to skip school to protest the
weather here is young 16 year old Greta
the great expert that the Democrats are
calling in talking about the perils of
climate change on Capitol Hill I have
not come to offer any prepared remarks
at this hearing I'm instead attaching my
testimony it is the IPCC special report
on global warming of 1.5 degrees Celsius
the SR 1.5 which was released on October
8 2018 I am submitting this report as my
testimony because I don't want you to
listen to me I want you to listen to the
scientists and I want you to put unite
behind the science and then I want you
to take real action thank you this
testimony is the perfect encapsulation
of leftist politics you have meaningless
slogans uttered without any arguments by
ignorant children with no respect for
national borders that is left ISM in a
nutshell
you have this girl come she actually was
very smart not to give testimony and not
to give her own remarks why because
she's a sixteen year old girl and she
doesn't know anything and it would
embarrass her so she knew well not to do
that and so she said I'm here and my
remarks are going to be the IPCC report
on climate change okay what does that
mean here's the report and there are a
few reports from the International Panel
on Climate Change what is the
implication of it what is the
consequence of that I mean this you you
have the left tell us we need to base
our politics on science politics is
about how we're gonna live together it's
about what we should do it's not just
making observations about the world it's
interpreting the world it's interpreting
those facts and science and observations
and then deciding what to do with that
and what the effect of that will be on
how we govern ourselves so you can't
just attach some scientific study even
if it's a highly politicized one like
the IPCC report and say okay here's your
government that's not good enough we're
not just a machine there's not just a
clear answer what we do in deliberative
bodies what we do in self-government is
interpret the world and then decide how
we want to to govern ourselves this is
what the left does though these
meaningless slogans these constant the
promotion of ignorant children some of
them very overgrown children no respect
for national borders why are we
listening to the Swedish girl you
couldn't even find a 16 year old
American girl to talk about this no of
course not and empty and
counterproductive stunts so the only
reason you might have heard of this girl
Greta thun thun berg is because she just
pulled another big stunt this was only
about a month or two ago she took a
transatlantic voyage on a zero-carbon
yacht what is the zero-carbon yacht I I
don't know
the zero-carbon yacht is a ship that she
took across the Atlantic Ocean that was
not going to pollute the environment
even though the ships made of plastic
and so obviously the construction of it
hurt the environment and it's 4 million
pounds so you're looking at what 6
million dollars or more for this boat I
mean it was just a really nice but
60-foot Malizia 2 yacht it was
fitted out with solar panels and
underwater turbines that produce the
electricity on board so wasn't burning
any fossil fuels it wasn't ostensibly
harming the environment so she said she
was going to take this carbons carbon
free boat trip across the Atlantic to
raise awareness about climate change
that trouble for this stunt though is it
later came out that while she did take
the zero carbon yacht across the water
so she wasn't polluting the environment
by flying on an airplane for instance
two people had to fly out to America on
a jet to take the ship back to Europe so
it wasn't sure if she just flown to
America on an airplane she would have
had much of a less of much less of an
effect on the environment that if she
did this whole big stunt two people fly
out to take the boat back to Europe and
then there were other reports that two
more people flew out to meet up with
Greta why because she's a 16 year old
girl she needs antlers you're not gonna
go across the Atlantic Ocean and hang
out in America all by herself so so this
stunt in the end I suppose it raised
awareness but it didn't raise awareness
for global warming it raised awareness
about the hypocrisy of environmental
activists again I don't really blame her
for this 16 year olds do this all the
time teenagers are constantly pulling
grandiose stunts and having too much
self regard but I do blame the adults
one for exploiting her and two for
encouraging this nonsense it occurred to
me climate change is the perfect issue
for teenagers to get upset about
it's the absolute perfect issue because
it fulfills everything teenagers are
longing for that grandiosity that
outside self regard and even religious
longings you know we're seeing
increasingly this is certainly true in
Sweden as it is here in America that
teenagers Gen Z and Millennials were
raised without religion but everybody
has religious longings everybody has a
sense of the divine a sense of purpose
in the world a hope that what they're
doing has meaning that their life has
meaning and so because politics has
become religion for the left
environmentalism climate change fulfills
those longings and for teenagers to come
out and say I'm gonna save the world
that's all you ever want to do I mean
when you're a teenager you feel that you
don't have power you feel that you're
coming into your own but you're being
held back by rules by your parents by
your schooling by not being able to
fulfill your grand dreams and all you
want to do is go ahead and so we're
going to make a difference we're gonna
change the world they're gonna get
famous they're gonna have influence
climate change fulfills all of that at
least in one's mind that's fine
teenagers want to do that teenagers do
stupid things all the time it's far less
appropriate though for adults to get all
revved up about this so she comes out
there she does as good a job as she
possibly could I think testifying on
Capitol Hill and she says I've attached
the UN report why she attached the UN
report because she has nothing to say
the more and more you hear the left say
we need to listen to the scientists so
well then how come the chief spokesman
on this issue is Al Gore how come the
other spokesmen on this issue is is this
Swedish teenager I don't really hear a
whole lot from the scientists and by the
way government isn't a scientific
endeavor politics isn't a scientific
endeavor politics is essentially about
speech about persuasion about values
about ethics about virtue about how we
want to live together I mean these are
mcgann I suppose the ultimate reason why
it was good to have a 16 year old on
this issue is because it's a fantasy
issue I mean every day we're told we
have less and less time to live
AOC says Miami is not going to exist
within two years so that's fine they're
talking about these fantasy issues but
how is that going to play in 2020
because if they had something real to
campaign on I think they would I think
this focus on the climate change or on
ar-15s or on these really niche issues
that they're going very extreme it's
coming from a place of not having
anything else to run on
I can't run on the economy can't run on
war can't run on suffering can't run on
unemployment can't run on any of those
things I materially and just from a very
basic level things are going pretty well
you see this not just on climate change
you see this even on other long-standing
issues like gun control you now have
Democratic presidential candidates
openly calling for gun confiscation
Kamala Harris has come at she's joined
bado or ork and a number of others in
saying we need to not only ban assault
weapons not only stop producing them not
only stop selling them not only buy them
back we need mandatory buybacks which is
an unbelievable
Orwellian politically correct phrase
which is a euphemism for stealing here's
Kamala Harris talking about how she's
gonna steal your guns weapons are
weapons of war be clear about this
assault weapons are designed to kill a
lot of people quickly there is no reason
that they should exist on the streets of
a civil society the assault weapon term
which is a made-up term from just the
last 30 years I think this is the one
appropriate use of it because right now
Kamala Harris is taking a flamethrower
to a field of straw men you know this is
how you know that the left doesn't have
an argument on gun control or global
warming or and really anything else the
way that you know that they don't have
an argument on this is they keep using
all these euphemisms assault weapons
mandatory buyback weapons of war what
what is an assault weapon conservatives
ask this all the time because the
definition changes every single day
because it's a made-up term from the
1980s that the left started to use to
confuse people about semi-automatic
rifles where you pull the trigger once
and one round comes out and they wanted
them to conflate that with fully
automatic weapons which have been
illegal in the United States more or
less illegal for decades and decades all
weapons are assault weapons all wet 100
percent of weapons or assault weapons
even perfectly innocuous things can
become assault weapons if you use them
to assault people the purpose of weapons
is assault that's what they're there for
they're not there just to look really
good mounted over your fireplace they're
not there so that you can just clean it
you know sitting on your front porch
spitting tabacky into a spittoon they're
there to assault people they're there to
shoot people they're there to kill
people weapons of war all weapons are
weapons of war the chief end of weaponry
is war it's about inflicting violence on
other people
what about mandatory gun buybacks this
is my favorite one this is a one that is
really cropped up over time first of all
even if it were just a buyback forget
the mandatory for a second even if bado
and Kamala Harris were talking just
about buybacks the government can't
issue a gun buyback because I didn't buy
my gun from the government in the first
place I bought my gun from a store
I guess the store could offer to buy
back my gun but the government cannot I
didn't get my gun from the government I
got my gun to protect myself against the
government if things ever go crazy and I
got to get out of Dodge then you add on
the mandatory part and it gets even more
ridiculous so it's not it's not a
buyback the government basic adjustments
to take your weapons away and they're
offering to pay you a little bit for it
when you add mandatory to it it's no
longer even buying I mean buying implies
the free exchange of goods and services
it implies that you're purchasing
something okay I want this good and so
I'm gonna part with my money to get that
good when you add in mandatory buyback
that's just a euphemism a euphemism for
theft for stealing for confiscation but
they don't want to use those terms
they'll let you know the left always
does this instead of talking about
killing babies they talk about
protecting women's health care has
nothing to do with the actual act which
is killing babies but they use these
euphemisms because they know the reality
of it is too unpopular and in this case
the reality of it is unconstitutional we
have a Second Amendment in this country
but if you have mandatory buyback so
there's no such thing as a Second
Amendment now it doesn't really matter
what Kamala Harris and bado or works say
in and of itself because their campaigns
are going absolutely nowhere and there
they're going nowhere actually in part
because they keep flip-flopping for
political convenience on all of these
important issues but just listen to it
listen to bethe will work just two or
three months ago saying he's not gonna
take away your guns compared to beta or
ork just a week ago saying hell yes
we're going to take your ar-15
are you proposing taking away their guns
and how would this work I am if it's a
weapon that was designed to kill people
on a battlefield if the high impact high
velocity round when it hits your body
shreds everything inside of your body
because it was designed to do that so
that you would bleed to death on a
battlefield not be able to get up and
kill one of our soldiers when we see
that being used against children and in
odessa i met the mother of a 15 year old
girl who was shot by an ar-15 and that
mother watched her bleed to death over
the course of an hour because so many
other people were shot by that ar-15 in
Odessa in Midland there weren't enough
ambulances to get to them in time hell
yes we're gonna take your ar-15 your
ak-47
you you may not have listened to the the
last part of that clip because he loses
you in the first sentence with one of
the stupidest statements I've yet heard
in this 2020 campaign which is really
saying something he says yeah we're
gonna ban the guns if the guns were
designed to kill people if the weapons
were designed to kill people we're gonna
ban them what does he think guns are for
what do these people think even if they
sometimes they twist what the Second
Amendment is the Second Amendment is
about protecting you and your rights and
your freedom but they'll say well it's
really for hunting it's not there's no
the framers didn't add it to the Bill of
Rights to protect your right to go shoot
a bunny rabbit but even if it were they
killed the bunny rabbit when you go
hunting you kill the animal the purpose
of guns is to kill people and to kill
animals but the reason I bring up bado
is because of the flip how quick this
was this is bado just a few months ago
saying I'm not gonna take your guns then
bado
a week or so ago saying hell yes I'm
gonna take your guns to be clear they
should have them if you purchase that
ar-15 if you own it keep it continue to
use it responsibly hell yes we're gonna
take your ar-15 your ak-47 hell yes
we're gonna take your ar-15 your ak-47
there it is and it just teaches
Republicans not to trust Democrats on
this issue and in the next time that the
Democrats make fun of us and this we're
not gonna take your gun stop it you
catastrophists we're not gonna take your
guns you point to bait or work you say
this isn't look he's kind of a loser
he's not gonna have a major influence on
American politics but the guy was a
top-tier Senate candidate and he lost
and for a while he was a top two your
presidential candidate among the
Democrats and then he wasn't
but you know we had the Vanity Fair
cover spread the Democrats were talking
about him as though he was the next
Obama he's still on that debate stage
for some reason very prominent Democrat
who did it within just two or three
months completely flipped said he's
going to take your guns doesn't play
very well you know people know people
get
the silent majority I guess I guess we
can't call it the silent majority like
when we were talking about Trump
supporters in California but you could
at least call it the silent plurality
you could at least call it a a large
group of voters who just see through it
you know we were talking earlier this
week about the political philosopher
James Burnham's ten rules ten laws and
the first one is everybody knows
everything people know the ar-15s aren't
the problem so few people relatively are
killed each year with ar-15s you are
between 22 and 23 times as likely to be
killed with a handgun as you are with a
rifle of any kind any kind of rifle
including the dred ar-15 or ak-47 people
know this and it's this is especially
true of people who actually know what
weapons are you actually have some
experience with guns I mean it's always
so ironic that the people who were
trying to take your guns trying to
abolish the Second Amendment through
brute force who are trying to regulate
all of your weapons don't actually know
anything about it it's actually good for
us it's good for gun owners it gives us
an advantage because they write up some
stupid law and they say okay now we got
it and we'll take away your guns and
then you make like two modifications to
the gun and then you're absolutely fine
I mean they just did that in California
they don't know what they're talking
about he says we're not gonna ban any of
the guns except the ones designed to
kill people oh okay great that sounds
good I mean I was on a Fox show last
night I was on martha maccallum show
with one Williams I liked one Williams
very much is a very intelligent guy he
doesn't know anything about guns and so
he mentioned on this show how we need to
ban AR 47s I don't bring this up just to
make fun of one for not knowing a lot
about guns I think he's actually
representative of a lot of people on the
left in this country of course there's
no such gun is an AR 47 there are ak-47
there's an ar-15 but the left
especially the elite left especially the
chattering class especially the leftist
politicians they have a completely
different view on guns than people who
actually use them so they just see big
scary gun looks like a military gun
looks like an automatic weapon bad Banat
everyone's going to agree with us
they're not they're not everybody knows
and I we are we're talking about my
ironic corollary to everybody knows
which is everybody knows everything and
nobody knows anything specifically the
people who don't know that everybody
knows everything are the ones who don't
know anything and that is
disproportionately the self-appointed
elite the chattering class the
Democratic candidates for president
they're not so clever those guys they're
not so smart believe it or not the hoi
polloi the proletariat the masses of
Americans are usually a little bit
cleverer a little bit smarter a little
bit wiser a little bit more
knowledgeable than those self-appointed
elites they know what guns are for they
know why they have guns they know why
they have a Second Amendment and the
issue is not rifle regulations we've had
rifle regulations before we'll have
rifle regulations again I don't favor
most rifle regulations I think most of
them are unconstitutional that's a fair
matter for public debate the issue here
is the mandatory buyback people know
their constitutional rights people do
not want the government to come in and
steal their property people do not want
the government to come in kick in the
door and take away their right to defend
themselves that is a massive overreach
it's a massive overreach for the
candidates who are pushing it and
obviously it would be a massive
overreach for the government and you
don't need to be a gun enthusiast to
oppose that I mean it's it's the same
thing of Trump in California I mean
somehow the left is making even Donald
Trump appealing to many liberals in
California even many liberals in
Hollywood called out willing grace Debra
Messing and Eric McCormack for calling
for a blacklist many liberals in
California hate the homelessness crisis
because of Democratic mismanagement in
that city many liberals in California
hate the drug epidemic and the needles
on the street and the public defecation
you don't need to be a conservative to
oppose public defecation I think that's
an issue that crosses party lines left
right and center you can oppose that
it's the same thing with these cut you
don't need to be a Rock rib conservative
a Republican a gun owner a gun nut like
they call us to oppose the government
coming in and stealing your property and
taking away your constitutional rights
and
more they keep this up the better
Republican chances are in 2020 the more
they keep this up the more that silent
majority or at least that silent
plurality sits there and says now this
is too far I can't let this happen I
don't like the mean tweets but I'm gonna
have to vote for that guy we actually
got some even more good news on that
culture this week so is some good news
and there's some bad news we'll start
with the good news first the number of
abortions in the United States has
fallen to the lowest level since 1973 we
will examine why that is we will exact
as there's it's a good reason why there
isn't is that kind of a bad reason as to
why that's happening but but we may be
turning a corner on abortion we'll get
to that and some bad news for criminal
justice from the New York Times to Pope
Francis sometimes it's difficult to tell
the difference between those two things
and then an embarrassing report on
Millennials why because today is a day
that ends in Y it was seem to come out
every single day but you got to go to
daily wire.com ten bucks a month $100
for an annual membership you get me you
get the Andrew Klavan show you get the
Ben Shapiro show you test questions in
the mailbag that's gonna be coming up
tomorrow so make sure you get your
questions in you get another Kingdom
which we're recording now and it's super
cool the story is great I think the
third season is actually better than the
first two you'll get all that and you
will get your leftist ears tumblr and
you're gonna need that leftist ears
tumblr you're gonna need a 15 million
leftist tears coming out of California
in just the past few days go over to the
daily wire so that you don't drown we
will be right back
some really great news on the abortion
front this week just after that awful
story came out about the the abortionist
who had two thousand baby body parts
found at his home I was pretty gruesome
and grisly we get a report from the
Guttmacher Institute which is a
pro-abortion Institute it's affiliated
with Planned Parenthood they are showing
that the number of abortions in the
United States has fallen to the lowest
level since 1973 so what they found is
that in 2017 that's the most recent year
they got the numbers for there were
eight hundred and sixty two thousand
abortions in the United States now that
number is still so horrifying I mean
eight hundred and sixty-two thousand
babies human persons cute little lives
snuffed out at the behest of their own
mothers by so-called doctors whose job
it is to heal and help people and to
instead are using forceps and vacuums to
murder them on mass I don't want it to
sound like this is too rosy a story here
eight hundred sixty-two thousand
abortions in the United States is eight
hundred and sixty-two thousand too many
abortions still that is down from a
previous report from the GUP mocker
Institute from 2014 showing nine hundred
and twenty six thousand abortions so
you're down about 60,000 abortions in
just three years that's pretty good and
actually there were over a million
abortions counted in 2011 so the number
is decreasing I mean that's that's
pretty good if you can save 150,000
babies a year so it's a good thing as
worth celebrating
gute mocker is also by the way the only
entity that that tries to count all of
these abortions in the United States and
makes inquiries of the private
abortionists so this is pretty a pretty
reliable data it's at least the best
data that we have why are abortions
decreasing part of the reason they're
decreasing is actually that there are
fewer pregnancies so I guess that's not
great
News I mean we have a dying population
we're well below replacement rate right
now for the American population you need
about 2.1 babies per couple and we're
about 1.7 so we're still in a tough
situation and this has effects not just
obviously on the people and not just on
the health of the country but it's one
of the reasons for instance why we rely
so heavily on immigration is our economy
would likely collapse if we totally cut
off immigration now we have to import
well over a million people a year
legally and then another million people
a year illegally if we just cut out the
abortion and got our birth rate back up
I mean the numbers work out almost
perfectly we would be a replacement rate
and the need for immigration not we
obviously would still debate whether
certain immigration levels are desirable
or beneficial to the country but the
need for it would disappear overnight
almost exactly so that is bad news still
good news that we're killing fewer
babies and I think we're turning a
corner on this I think we're turning a
corner on this issue I was hosting Ben's
radio show yesterday I talked to Abby
Johnson who is a former Planned
Parenthood staffer who is rising up the
ranks and then she saw an abortion on an
ultrasound and she instantly became a
pro-life that activist and advocate she
left planned parent now he's one of the
biggest pro-life voices in the country
seeing that ultrasound I think is
helping to reduce the number of
abortions in the country you can see it
and it's not just a little black and
white blob you can see the baby in three
dimensions really early on you can just
tell that is a baby that looks like a
baby now it's not even an argument I
mean we should know that abortion is
wrong and abortion is evil just using
our own faculties of reason in our own
logic a person's a person no matter how
small we know it's living we know it's
human you shouldn't kill innocent human
life simple enough but the optics matter
seeing is believing
and when you see that that's a baby
something stirs in you emotionally and
you say I can't kill that I should not
kill that I don't even really like
babies you know I'm not like a warm and
fuzzy guy exactly I don't like puppies I
don't like babies that much I like some
babies but not all babies but when
someone hands you a baby you're gonna
hold a baby
you just feel this natural care for it
you want to protect it you certainly
don't want to kill it
that is some of the good news on the
culture seeing is believing I saw this
this headline from The Guardian the
British newspaper and the headline said
unborn babies exposed to toxic air
pollution and this is a really telling
headline unborn babies exposed to toxic
air pollution except the mainstream
media left-wing papers don't tend to
refer to unborn babies do they what do
they refer to fetuses embryos clump of
cells they don't refer to the unborn
babies which is what they are they don't
refer to the unborn babies when they're
talking about whether or not we should
kill them they only refer to the unborn
babies to pull on our heartstrings while
we're talking about global warming which
is a leftist policy issue then they talk
about it you know you never hear when
some princess in the UK is about to have
a baby then it's the Royal baby it's not
the Royal clump of cells it's not the
royal foetus it's the baby because we
know it's a baby but when it's
politically convenient for them they
hide it they can't really hide it so
much anymore
it's becoming clearer that that those
euphemisms you know all those deceptive
slogans that the left uses to try to
push their fantasies on the silent
majority of people who get it who know
who understand what's going on those
euphemisms are cracking they're falling
apart and we're looking and we're saying
now that's a baby shouldn't do that you
can scream you can shout your abortion
you're gonna have Alyssa Milano screech
all she wants on Twitter you're not
gonna convince me to disbelieve my own
eyes that's some good news on the
culture some bad news on the culture
coming from the New York Times and from
Pope Francis and I sort of repeat myself
when I say that this is on the question
of life imprisonment the left is turning
against life imprisonment the left
already opposes the death penalty almost
uniformly many conservatives now even
oppose the death penalty now they're
moving to opposing life imprisonment and
I only bring up this story in all of my
humility to say I told you so I called
it I knew this would happen one of the
arguments against the death penalty you
had there are a lot of incoherent
arguments you hear
people say we need to get rid of the
death penalty because it's a it's better
you know it's it would be better to lock
the person up in jail forever it gives
them hope it gives them their life it
doesn't take their life away then you
hear the people say we need to get rid
of the death penalty because the death
penalty is too good for them life
imprisonment is way worse and we want to
torture them and which I I don't agree
with either of those things but the
argument that we need to get rid of the
death penalty in the service of justice
was never a good argument the reason
people are clamoring against the death
penalty is because they don't understand
justice they think that the criminal
justice system is only about
rehabilitation rehabilitation is only
one of the three reasons for the
criminal justice system and it is by far
the least important one the three
reasons our rehabilitation sure also
deterrence deterring other criminals and
most importantly retribution punishment
for the crime justice itself that's the
most important one look we could all use
a little rehabilitation okay we all have
personal behaviors that we could amend
should we all go to prisons should we
all go to rehabilitation correctional
centers no of course not there would be
a mass public outcry if you took your
brother who's annoying you and saying oh
we got to get you to that Correctional
Center so you get a little more correct
so you got rehabilitated you go to
prison because you committed crimes you
go to prison as a punishment and as a
way to in some way restore and exact
justice justice is the purpose and so if
you get rid of the death penalty you're
not going to have a clearer sense of
justice you're going to have a less
clear sense and that's what's happening
with life imprisonment so the New York
Times came out with this piece a little
while ago they said how would you spend
a life sentence for one inmate a new
federal law gave hope where there had
been none imagine at the age of 28
you're told that you're gonna spend the
rest of your life in prison with no
chance of release would you what would
you do with all that time there's no
shame in admitting you'd want to throw
in the towel it's a rational reaction to
a hopeless situation remember we were
told that the death penalty was hopeless
life in prison gave you
now we're told no that's hopeless -
pretty soon we're gonna be told that if
you have to sleep it off one night in
jail that's hopeless - the times goes on
why bother working to improve yourself
learning something new or making amends
if nothing you do will ever make a
difference
Gary Ryan's now 46 had every reason to
choose that route after receiving a
mandatory sentence of life without
parole and then it goes on and talks
about how he's been a good prisoner and
he got his high school diploma in prison
and he's like a really nice guy and they
conclude this summer all those years of
hard work paid off at a hearing on July
24th and Harrisburg Pennsylvania federal
district court judge Johnny Jones the
third re sentenced mr. Rhines to time
served in his case 18 years which
includes nearly three years of pretrial
detention that was the New York Times
Pope Francis comes out says basically
the same thing I mean the message from
The Times is clear we need to get rid of
life imprisonment Pope Francis said it
even more clearly Pope Francis came out
and he said it is up to every society to
ensure that the penalty does not
compromise the right to hope that press
prospects for reconciliation and
reintegration are guaranteed life
imprisonment is not the solution to
problems I repeat life imprisonment is
not the solution to problems but a
problem to be solved that is what the
Pope is saying this is the same Pope who
came out against the death penalty just
a few months ago and attempted to
radically change 2,000 years of Catholic
moral teaching this comes from a
fundamental misunderstanding of justice
and we're talking about it now as though
this is compassionate I mean Joe Biden
is your Joe Biden at the debate just the
other night he came out and he said
nonviolent criminals should not go to
prison here he is nobody should be in
jail for a non-violent crime what does
that mean so if you commit fraud if you
commit bank fraud a white-collar crime
you shouldn't go to jail only poor
people disproportionately ethany
minorities only they should go to jail
but disproportionately white wealthy
people they should never go to jail for
their crimes
even though fraud is a much worse crime
and more serious sin than robbing a
liquor store doesn't make any sense
it's a misunder
standing of justice from Joe Biden to
the Pope to the New York Times a
fundamental misunderstanding of it and I
saw the rot setting in with the death
penalty but everyone a lot of
conservatives oppose the death penalty -
I don't death penalty is a good thing
it's important for the civil authority
to have the death penalty for all three
of those reasons by the way for
retribution for deterrence and even
rehabilitation hanging concentrates the
mind as dr. Johnson pointed out when dr.
Johnson the famous English writer said
when a man knows to be eased to be
hanged in a fortnight it concentrates
his mind wonderfully it can really
reform you really have you make peace
with your God make some sense out of
your life when you're looking at the
gallows and then regardless of that
that's a conversation for another day
the reason the society needs in the
death penalty is it gives us a sense of
justice and as that erodes very very
quickly as you're seeing just months
later the next punishment is going to
erode and then it's going to be no more
30 years and then it's gonna be no more
20 years and then it's gonna be no more
jails period and we're going to get into
a smiley smiley correctional sense we're
gonna get rid of the criminal justice
system it's just going to be criminal
rehabilitation giving the government
more and more arbitrary power and taking
away our compassion for victims of
crimes taking away deterrence and
ultimately taking away justice not good
news and I will end today's show on even
worse news though it's very expected
Millennials are bad tippers I'm not
surprised at all I'm not so a new study
came out from creditcards.com finding
that in general men and Millennials are
the worst tippers now I was a little
surprised to find out that men are worst
tippers than women part of this might be
there was one flaw with the study they
pointed this out I think over at hot air
which is that as they did it just based
on credit card tips but a lot of people
tip in cash because I'm if you've ever
worked as a server I have you want to
get the cash tips won because you don't
want the IRS to know about everything
and to because sometimes the restaurants
themselves go in there and take some of
your money if it's on credit cards but
Millennials don't carry cash so
I think with Millennials it's just about
tipping not surprised at all Millennials
are often excoriated as a selfish
generation and all sell of just obsessed
with themselves and greedy and all in it
for themselves and also broke because
they have a lot of debt and this would
seem to bear that out
I just would like for any of the
Millennials listening hear me out
tip well tip well always tip well tip
your servers they're working a tough job
if you ever work that job you know it's
a tough job they're working for tips
except I guess now in these cities that
are raising the minimum wage to $700 but
generally speaking if you're working on
waiting tables job you're working for
tips you're not going to miss the extra
dollar or two you're not gonna miss it
you don't need it and if you're going
out to eat you're going out to drink and
you've got enough money to tip your
server well come on Millennials have
some self-respect it's not it's not even
just about them it's about you yourself
what kind of man you're gonna be all
right that's my PSA for Millennials
that's our show we've got a lot more to
get to but we'll have to do it tomorrow
get your mailbag questions in in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show see them
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel white
house key edited by Danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by Mike or Amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation